[Music]
atena it is great to be here with you
thank you for coming thanks for having
me so I want to talk first about your
your founding story tell me about how
you founded your company yeah so I think
I I always knew I love startups and
because of that I I wanted to be an
investor someday because you can help
people start companies and not just do
it once but help many different people
during Co I kind of realized I wanted to
spend more time with Founders and I
didn't have enough personal Capital to
be an angel investor at that point so I
ended up raising a very small like micr
fund 600k from one LP and I started
using that to write Small Checks on
nights and weekends as soon as I started
not only investing but starting base
case and realizing that it was the
entrepreneurial aspect of figuring out
how I'm going to get in front of people
cuz I didn't have a background as an
investor I didn't have any firm name on
the wall to to show you know here's why
you should take a meeting with me and I
was just kind of reaching out to
interesting people or being connected to
to people through my network and as soon
as I started writing those checks I
realized I loved it and I wanted to do
it
full-time is there any particular Focus
you're looking on when you invest in
people is there any particular
Industries or categories or people
you're really excited about yeah so base
case is a little bit different and I
like to say I spend all of my time with
Founders before are actually Founders so
unlike most VCS I don't really take
pitch meetings I am mostly talking to
the brightest engineers and maybe second
time Founders whose companies were
Acquired and sort of getting to know
them when they are just in the thick of
it whether they are just learning how to
adapt as a company scales and so I try
to figure out how I can help them
introduce them to maybe some of my
portfolio Founders to talk about their
journey and eventually whenever they're
ready to leave and start a company I try
to write the first check in because
often times it's really before someone
actually knows what it is that they're
going to
build so what's it been like as a woman
to navigate in this ridiculously male
dominated VC industry have you faced any
big challenges the first fund I raised
was a $20 million fund and I started
raising it and I still remember about a
week into that I looked at my air table
tracking of the investors and there was
probably one woman and I was like okay
after this week I need to only talk to
women and underrepresented minorities in
Tech and that's what I did I lowered the
minimum check size historically funds
have sort of a crazy minimum like 250k
to invest lowered that to 5K was the the
lowest track and without a doubt the the
women and the the people that I
typically don't think would have made it
into the fund if I had stuck with sort
of the typical Norm of 250k minimum are
the people who are most interesting to
me if you could give yourself one piece
of advice the day before you started
your company what would you tell
yourself that you wish you had known
that you know now I would say lean
into what makes you you and forget about
what people traditionally do in this
role when I first started I looked at
all the other investors and I said okay
you know typical investor is meeting
companies that are actively raising they
are looking at decks and they're asking
really smart questions and there are a
lot of great investors that do that and
I thought that that's what I had to do
and it really took me like a couple
years to realize actually what I'm
really good at which not a lot of other
people are good at is just finding great
people and building relationships and
seeing things in people before anyone
else does and so what I sort of ort of
realized over the last two years is like
whenever I do that it ends up being a
really successful
company and one last question for you
and this is a lofty one so you can take
a second what would you like your legacy
to be for me it's not enough just to be
an investor in great companies I want to
be someone that those Founders say you
know she believed in me and she sort of
gave me the conviction to go and build
something and I think the the goal that
I have with Bas case is to you know give
people confidence in themselves that
they can go and build something and give
them all the resources they need to go
and do that so if I can just inspire
people to to go build and give them the
the sort of push to to you know jump off
the diving board I think that's what my
goal
[Music]
is